[Inaudible]
cool.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Okay. All right. I hope you enjoyed this video. So, I mean,
let's take a break. You want something to drink? Oh, it's a Coca-Cola.
Yeah, sure. Do you want a glass? Let's go get a glass. All right,
let me just grab one. Oh my God.
What this video is sponsored by brilliant.org.
I did not expect that anyways. I will continue to video after this message,
by the way, this video was sponsored by brilliant.org,
which is kind of cool because I actually use trillian.org.
When I was applying to my untitled large company,
since the company gave me links to help me prepare for my interview.
And one of the links that they gave me is a bunch of competent torics questions.
AKA probably questions on brilliant.org.
It really helped me on the math part of the interview because I was killing the
probability questions.
I actually find it really fun to crank out these questions.
It makes me feel good about myself and keeps me sharp.
And they're good brain teasers for interviews,
especially for data science or quantum.
Very good supplement to my interview preps. So highly recommended. Also,
if you're in school,
you could supplement your learning by using this website because there's a wide
variety of topics, which is pretty dope.
Cause I love the UI on the website and it makes studying so much more fun with
their quizzes. If you're interested,
there's a link in the description down below. Best of all,
you can get 20% off their premium subscription. So YouTube,
you can kill it at the interview for the large entitled company. All right.
Thanks for watching this video. If you like it,
don't forget to like and subscribe. And I also want to shout out to Jared,
thank you for supporting this channel. And we got one question from honey.
What do you do during weekends? Well,
I do a lot of stuff I film and then I edit my video.
Sometimes I hang out with Matt Cho. I like to try new restaurants.
I like to go to the gym. That's pretty fun.
I do a little bit of rock climbing and then if it's during the winter I go
snowboarding. So yeah, that's pretty much it. Thanks for watching.
[Inaudible].
Right.